hello good people
I am Francesca and for those of you who
start following the emmys men following
the news for the week I have three words
for you no really I have three words for
you here are three top stories of the
past seven days reduced to mere
syllables
this is words of the week Hellfire no
not the eternal pit of lava you'll be
going to for coveting thy neighbor's
cable package it's an american-made
missile you may remember from such as
des Israel's latest assault on Gaza
it's what struck a UN school of air on
August 3rd killing 10 civilians an act
the US State Department called
disgraceful Obama then halted the
shipment of more Hellfires to israel
surely out of moral outrage actually no
he did it cuz just when he was trying to
browbeat netanyahu into laying off
palestinians that we bit the pentagon
was still selling weapons to their
Mideast bestie without White House
approval but this week after said
Hellfire hiccup the White House called
game on to military assistance one
reason it's good business
each Hellfire costs between 70 to a
hundred thousand dollars but is a
non-stop weapons flow adding fuel to the
mmm Hellfire icy reach something that
really should be called I see you all of
you I see reaches a search engine of
none other than the NSA that combed
through mountains of personal
information and offers it up to the Sun
gods of the FBI CIA DEA and dia
according to documents released via the
intercept by their homeboy ed Snowden IC
reach was created to be the US largest
system for sharing surveillance records
making 850 billion available to a
thousand analysts spanning 23 government
agencies which sounds about as secure as
your mom's Facebook password we're
talking private phone calls GPS location
emails and internet chat messages I know
you're thinking are your snapchat safe
IC reach can also collect your religious
affiliation and political beliefs and
gives the government tips as to where
you might go next guess you shouldn't
have said yes to the Batman cosplay
extravaganza ecstasy a mental state
of extreme delight and the illegal drug
that produces a similar emotion thanks
to the chemical compound MDMA commonly
associated with glowsticks house music
and white dreadlocks which comes in
slowly decorated little pills and this
week the Burmese Navy confiscated 2.4
million of these love beans hidden on a
ship near the country's border with
Thailand authorities said the haul was
worth about 200 million dollars the
biggest they'd ever found ie enough to
host literally the most epic rave in the
history of the universe not clear why
the Navy was so shocked Myanmar is no
spring chicken on synthetic drugs they
are the biggest producers of them in
Southeast Asia just act surprised and
those were your words of the week and
now back to the director of true
detective hello subscribe on YouTube
follow us on Twitter and like us on
Facebook